three-time Super Bowl champion Michael
Irvin is here on the track I love the
live audience reaches it always brings
something special to a show we have the
live audio just just to be seeing the
people and my man right here with the
Champ Bailey stuff for him when the
camera comes by he's waving his World
Championship flat you know that's from
2016 okay just okay just as long as you
know but you're waving it like y'all
gone initial there's three years ago I
just want to make sure you know that
bring you I'm glad you've set the stage
properly could you imagine if we had a
live audience on game day my oh my oh my
god when you when you're when you're
starting to get into your proselytizing
on Sunday morning you know when you're
starting to be some funds that I we get
some may midday means and all of that
yeah the whole audience howls we're lone
wolf
that would be great man you guys really
do you bring something it's fun when a
live audience is here it really it asks
so much to a show so also for a second
straight day we're gonna having on our
set for the first four days of our stay
here is in between the two of us an old
friend of yours that you've been with
three times oh yeah the Vince Lombardi
Trophy my baby right there - it's right
it's my baby it's right there right but
I know my baby I got a right thing I see
you sweet - sweet sweet got them things
man I was just telling everybody you
know this is what it's about right now
I've met a guy the other day and he was
I was still able to eat and like a
random already most of Greater T always
guys say they are they are but I said
you know IIIi like the people that win
ring when I ring
he said yeah okay they didn't win a ring
I said they didn't win one and I won I'm
an S brother I didn't wear a ring I want
rings
please and then I pause the moment you
know for effect I just paused and I said
also I won them on Lobos not just only
NFL college to our one rings on levels i
man s brother brother if you've got
plural you flaunt the plural who dare so
me brother what was it like was lifting
that for the first time though oh man I
never took that was our first Super Bowl
our Super Bowl 27 and Pasadena did I
remember score my first tech day yeah
understand everybody everybody that ever
picks up a football sits in his front
yard and dream about scoring the
touchdown in the Super Bowl and and
growing up his kid I was wasn't you know
the best kid maybe did some bad things
right
so they used always knock on the door
till my mom met whenever my Gerber boy
he's just he's ain't going out to
anything he just won't mount in it so I
scored my first touchdown
I just thought nah I got them all back
they saw that I just scored a touchdown
in the Super Bowl show all those people
they told my mom I wasn't going out to
anything they saw that that was the
greatest moment of my life and then
winning that thing and holding it up
rich Shh I would say I was the last
person to leave the locker room after we
won that trophy what do you mean
I was the last person I set that naked
for a while watch everybody come in go
we were I was the last one to leave and
it was it was just the crack I just
didn't want the moment the end you know
I could have put on some clothes but I
just did one momiji here it's not just
set yeah is that why you do that after a
great game day morning every Sunday
staying there all the way to the end
with no clothes on trying to absorb the
moment you know take all of that moment
just sitting in that moment it was it
really was incredible
because we had gone from year early
years going one in 15 and three or
thirteen and we were three four years
later kind of like the Rams are you know
two years ago to a 14 yeah kind of like
the Rams and you were in a Super Bowl
where nobody thought you would be and it
was just an incredible thing to get that
many people together that had a common
goal to focus on something and didn't
accomplish it and it's hard to do it
it's hard
unless you're new they're Patriots it's
hard to get to a Super Bowl Wow I mean
it's interesting that the brands are
going one state to another yeah by the
way by the way just the radio audience
you can hear this can I hear from the
Patriot fans in the audience just one
dude just a single guy here from behalf
the Patriots thing that that the
Patriots are for the lack of a better
phrase the Buffalo Bills team that you
faced an AFC East is making it in
multiple years obviously the bills never
won one and the Patriots have won
multiple but it's just an interesting
sort of parallel yeah that we can draw
here for this matchup
it is crazy when you think about
anything that was that our first one
that's our but it's oh the Buffalo has
all the experience you guys don't have
the experience same thing they're saying
about the Rams but it didn't matter that
yeah well it did but it couldn't in you
know just like if I'm on the Rams team
if I'm playing with I got to tell those
guys listen you know everybody makes all
that no it's about experience football
is football
football is football now you're going to
your 20 yard in there's a 20 yard in if
I'm doing it in a regular game I'm doing
it in the playoff I'm doing it in your
front yard our Super Bowl a 20 yard in
is do you say all that stuff but then
you get in games
you start breathing hard man maybe
football in just football great it is
some different you know
yeah Marshall said he wants patty passed
out almost in his first Super Bowl he
came out of the tunnel go let's go let's
go and he got dizzy he almost passed out
on the train exhausted I don't know what
it is so exact
you can be height before games but Super
Bowl you just I don't know it does
something to you and you're exhausted in
the first series you breathe air so hard
we just played one series and you're
breathing hard and you've got to be
careful if you never gone and that's
what the Rams got to be careful with
with because you got to manage your
emotions early on you have to manage
them because if not patrons man they'll
get a couple good scores in there and
you'll be down 14-0 before you know it
they have to manage their emotions and
understand you're going to be height and
you have to try to concentrate a focus
with that Michael Irvin here on the
recharge and show three-time Super Bowl
champion Hall of Famer and the man at
the other end of the set on game name
morning every single Sunday I love this
man known him from he wasn't my wedding
this man was at my wedding an MIT of my
wife's sitting there in an electric blue
tuxedo it's a fact century part it was
fact fact fact that we were all together
that day and God ordained us and who
spoke at my daughter's baby-naming said
oh right I love Michael Irvin baby name
is Sarah Moses we got we got great love
rich and you had a great opening line
you had a great opening line when the
rabbi introduced and I told him you know
all my life people have been calling me
Irving and Irwin and all of that so you
know that's why I mean I'm Jewish and
you were part of the NFL Network media
night last night a lot of great energy
last night and for a fourth straight
year the Rich Eisen show correspondent
for our media day back in the day when
he first started and media night last
night I'd like to bring up and put the
band back together from when you were on
the stage together at Super Bowl 50
way back in the day for
years ago put your hands together for
j.b smoove everybody man JB the ruckus
is being created here right back at you
that's a hell of a name JB Smoove yeah I
mean am i we could call you mi smooth
you know I mean we could do that sort of
thing yeah JB Smoove rolls which is
totally different category the plate
maker right
that's pretty cocky playmaker what was
your favorite interview from last night
oh man both of you guys yeah you know
what stone stone faced all the time you
know I like to get a little smirk out on
months in a while or make him think I'm
crazy you know I love him
no Bella check he's all my favorite what
you say to be some of the funniest
funniest one but it's always you know is
it true that you know of his nine
appearances you know every city's been
to does he check into hotels under the
name Samuel Adams true stare at me that
I'm crazy you know so you just didn't
like it stirred him that comes crazy so
I said it must be true what about you
are did grunt I'm not talking with drunk
man because I wanted to get some answers
because you know for the game and we did
on our show remember we said will we see
good old drunk or old lads grow
yeah and you answer Matt yes in that
right that's right trying out you know
cleaned it up a little bit for I try to
find out which because I thought you
know get in D we saw old ass drunk and
then just can't see we saw a good old
grump wrong said with the week off it
makes a huge difference so I think we'll
see good old grump because he has that
week off but I tried to get to see if
he's going to retire you know if he will
walk away from the game and and but he
said he wouldn't you know he waffled on
it he wouldn't get me anything as he has
other things there is wrestling and
acting I told him I said man stick with
that wrestling that actin ain't as easy
as you think
you know even if you think you can act
good right you got to get some job buddy
but a name i grok you figure he's do
something more rough like demolition or
butcher he'd be a good butcher Oh blood
some he just shows up once in a while in
other cities at all his locations and he
wouldn't even use a knife he'd use his
hand cause it was a good idea good idea
the butcher meat goes on the shirt what
about the ribs who did you speak to for
the ramps that would that was good both
you guys
well Donna I love Darren Donald right
you know I just I tried to get him up I
say the greatest coach of all time says
your unblockable and he said yeah I said
but these quarterbacks been untouchable
how can you get to him right now
and and he said well you know I just got
to get to him I got to get to him and
the guy's got a cover long enough on the
back on the back side so we can get to
him but I thought he's a phenomenal
phenomenal talent air Donald's
incredible dude I love watching him play
I think he should get the MVP yeah yeah
of the season
yes of the entire year more than I know
I know you're giving it I know you're
that I didn't stutter look yes I
confirmed you did not work right the
55,000 yard passing Patrick mahomes surf
yeah he's here he's here working on that
ring I think I told you about earlier
Eric Donald yes and her and Don was
working on that ring thing any think
about it in all this usually when a
person gets their money and he got paid
big time last year did they take a
little drop off yeah the next season you
know and I remember when I first got
Mike when I got my job I wanted to make
shots and I did I put up my purse I put
up my best year once I got my money too
but I don't know puts up his best year I
think it's important to show the people
that the money didn't stop you yeah and
he's showing he's showing people that I
mean just phenomenal clearable
incredible Wow incredible what about you
would you speak to j.b smoove both those
guys I I agree Mike big personalities
cool guys
sue was amazing to combine the two
together so I asked some alternate
questions kind of funny I'm at four I
say you know you guys are a perfect
pairing you know you guys dominate the
line both you guys are amazing what you
do you know I put you guys together like
other amazing Paris Paris like peanut
butter and jelly and magazines pick one
and tell me why you know who's chicken
who's waffle now sue said chicken and
waffles he said he would be the waffle
and Donald would be the chicken then I'm
waiting to ask Donald the same thing and
he said I'm a mac and cheese man myself
I would I would definitely be the Mac
and he would be the cheese I'll tell you
this is I appreciate you doing this I'm
tell you something rich yet I went hard
yesterday I caused major confusion a lot
of ruckus we're gonna see pass my rock
my Grunk interview may i cause confusion
the man I mean he always has a confused
look on his face anyway but
a man almost had to call the emergency
room and get score a today he was like
he needed a medic I had him on his heels
okay the game that we were all hoping to
see the sooo smooth summit that was
fantastic cheers good before I love
those questions great combination didn't
you ask Belichick one year his favorite
cookie with his favorite cookie wills
favorite cookie was I said are you more
of a Tucker chip guy or you are gonna
wafer guy or you more of a Fig Newton
guy he said
Belichick took that to the championship
earth before I let you go do you really
think Julian Edelman is a first-ballot
Hall of Famers you just said moments ago
when you were sitting on Dan Patrick
show I I didn't say Julian Edelman was
the first ballot Hall of Fame oh he is
not first Bell I'd say grump was okay
and Jason Witten was I just want to make
sure that we get this out right
now I'm not saying Julie alderman is not
a hall-of-famer okay but I didn't say
that
what well you know what if Edelman wins
a third ring and the guy who's got the
most famous catch in many ways in the
Boston Tea Party it was that catch that
he had sinker of beating the Falcons and
crowd no offense to the Atlanta fans
incredible right
this would be and also touchdown
receptions against the Seattle Seahawks
including surpass me with most yards
second year right another one of those
rice yeah so yeah you could be in third
place by Monday morning
yes absolutely I can't yeah and I guess
so I think Julian gets in that
conversation but now let's be running
out with receivers that's been different
you know getting in tight ends it's you
know these guys are clear-cut but I
think Julian Edelman with ultimate
ultimately become a Hall of Famer I
don't know if they will put him in the
first ballot okay but I think he is well
I think the last Randy was a first
ballot and then yeah and then Jerry Rice
was and that's it that's a hard on
receive some reason they just don't you
know they don't think we'd do anything
for the bags the quarterback thing you
put them in there anyway but you know
the receivers the guys they got a gold
run cut fake somebody out jump up now
catch the ball as this floating between
heaven and earth stop it right down is
actually while somebody's trying to take
off your head and then you start running
for it took that inside ain't nothing
Michael Irvin every pose
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience